[Music]
welcome to
session 48 of the worlds of speculative
fiction
series this time we are going to be
looking
at liu xin and
the remembrance of earth's past trilogy
this is the beginning of year six of
this monthly
series and we began as a
face-to-face lecture discussion kind of
book group
looking at at particular speculative
fiction authors
who had a narrative world to explore and
philosophical themes to discuss in the
time of covid we have switched to
doing this over the the net
electronically
through a video like this followed by a
in-depth discussion right after the
premiere of this video
and so seashen liu or lucy shin
is an author who has been suggested to
me a number of times we actually
had him slated to be covered
this last year and then it didn't happen
obviously because kovid brought
everything to a
grinding halt and so what we've got here
are the three books of this really great
series the three body problem a little
bit shorter
than the follow-up death's end and the
dark
forest and we're going to be exploring
some
philosophical themes in them
particularly the dark forest idea
and its connection to a hobbesian
view of the natural condition
no longer just for human beings but for
species in general
we'll be looking at lou's ideas
about the interrelations between
philosophy
science technology fiction
other genres we'll be looking at his
notion
of writing a history of
things yet to come an imaginative
history
and the connections that you can draw
between how he handles
world historical or even universe
historical themes
and its connections with individual
people the characters
will draw some connections with an
author who he talks about
in interviews quite a bit uh leo tolstoy
and there's a number of other really
important themes as well the notion of
you know going ahead in time
through cryogenics to a period where you
might be needed or could enjoy yourself
the nature of human interactions
and cultures and what we hold on to and
what we lose track of and how we get it
back
moral quandaries there's a lot of
different themes
i think that we can explore in the these
great works
and we'll also talk a little bit about
biography
um uh lucy shin is a currently living
author who has actually gotten a little
bit of hot water recently at least
here on on this side of the pacific
we'll talk about that in in just a bit
and we'll also talk about his views
on world building themselves and we have
to talk about
the narrative universe that he creates
in this before that though i want to
very briefly bring up another
work of his that i i highly recommend so
when when i
knew that i was going to be doing uh one
of these sessions and i thought it was
going to be a face-to-face session
on this trilogy here
i went to our local used bookstore half
price books which is actually a chain
and
i wanted to see what i could find by by
lucy shen
and they didn't have any of these in
stock
later on i was able to get my hands on
them but they did have
the wandering earth and the wandering
earth itself is a short story
but there's all sorts of other great
stories in here actually it's more of a
novella
i would say than a short story then
there's some other
great great ones in here as well that
are worth reading and it shows you the
range of uh his his thought
you know so this in addition to
these uh fairly significant tomes
are certainly worth delving into he has
a number of other books as well
that you can get your hands on that you
might want to check out but
this session is going to focus primarily
on
this trilogy which is very
rich and interesting i'm pleasantly
surprised
by what a great author and and the depth
of imagination
that um lucy shin shows
in in these works so with no further ado
why don't we jump into a bit of
discussion
about the actual story itself and
talk about the author and his biography
and we'll touch on a few other things
that are of interest before jumping
directly into philosophical themes
in these sessions we usually talk about
the biographies of the authors and and
this one will be
fairly short and kind of lead into
some of his discussions about the
writing
process but also some controversies that
leotze
shin has gotten involved in lately
without meaning to be involved in
controversies i think
but sort of stumbling his way into them
so he's born
in 1963 in
and his father had been a soldier
in the the communist army
right during the civil war between
nationalists and communists
his his father's uh brother the uncle
of of uh leo had also been a soldier but
he'd been on the nationalist side and
that would actually get his father
in some hot water during the cultural
revolution when
just about anything could get you
suspected so he ends up
having to take a manager's job in
the coal mine design institute his
mother
was a school teacher and lou was growing
up during
the cultural revolution a little bit of
background for those who don't
know too much about this so this is the
time after
you know the the communists had won and
and the nationalists
basically had to retreat to taiwan
and the country was you know largely
devastated it had not just gone through
a civil war but also
the war against the japanese and
when the communists attempted to
modernize and also at the same time you
might say
to idiol ideologize the entire country
at once there were a lot
of crises produced by that
a lot of conflict and
so this is this is the environment that
he's growing up in
at four years old he was actually sent
to live for a while with his
grandparents
in hanan so that you know he could be
away from
some of this this chaos and the you know
the the three body problem actually
begins
in that time with with you know um
some pretty graphic events that that we
can we can talk about a little bit later
so around this time that that you
is um growing up as a kid
he is seeing a china that is in the
process of modernizing it's actually
getting involved in the space race
at one time he had ambitions of being
involved in that in a more
direct way but then realized that
probably wasn't going to be
something accessible to him he also
encounters sci-fi
and speculative fiction his father gives
him jules verne's
journey to the center of the earth and
this
he said was was really instrumental for
him he
really enjoyed reading speculative
fiction
understood under the rubric of science
fiction which
arguably jules vernon really is
and he reads more and more and this is
actually a good place to take a pause
and talk a little bit about those that
he
he you know ascribes a certain kind of
influence to
so obviously jules verne is somebody who
he thinks is is quite important
in the background h.g wells jules vernon
both had an influence on
what was slowly developing in china as
you might say its own indigenous
science fiction um it wasn't really well
you know in part because of the the
difficulties of
um you know ideology under the
communists but also
just the the sheer devastation that had
taken place there wasn't as if there was
a big science fiction
industry or network or anything like
that but jules verne is important for
him
the author that he says was really the
most influential forum
it's not that big of a surprise is
arthur c
clarke who if you if you remember him
he not only you know wrote some pretty
important
hard science fiction and some quite
imaginative
what we could call sociological or new
wave
science fiction as well
but also made some significant
contributions the idea of geosynchronous
satellites
clark was one of the people who came up
with that right
so you know you can see why uh
leotsushin would be
attracted to him he also talks in in
some interviews about stanislaw
lemm the polish uh fiction author
speculative fiction science fiction
author whose works were read both behind
the iron curtain
and of course in china and in the west
he was able to get his his uh his works
out there um
so that's that's kind of an interesting
influence and lime actually has quite a
range we're also going to talk about lem
later in the
series this year ray bradbury is another
person who he mentions which is which is
kind of interesting i think that
a lot of us associate bradbury with
dystopia like you know fahrenheit 451
or with his weird slash
horror stuff but you know there's the
martian chronicles and and
ideas about exploration of space
and then he also talks about two other
authors who i think
are kind of interesting to bring in so
one of them is another
arguably dystopian author george orwell
and he says that
1984 made me realize that science
fiction novels can use different
perspectives to reflect
and criticize reality more so than
realistic literature so that's kind of
an interesting
thing to think about is 1984
a science fiction novel we don't usually
place it in that we call it like
dystopian literature
or something else but but you know i
guess you could consider it in a very
broad
sense science fiction if if there's not
so much
emphasis on the natural science and
there's more on the
social science aspect of it and then he
also talks about leo tolstoy
and he says that one of his favorite
works
is war and peace war and peace is of
course one of those books that so many
of us
have you know referenced sort of like
moby dick or you know so many other
things
the phenomenology of spirit where people
talk about it but very few people have
actually
read it from cover to cover let alone
multiple times
and war and peace you know is is
known in part for its sort of panoramic
sweep of of history and tolstoy actually
had some you know
discussions at the end about the nature
of of history itself
uh that are quite interesting to think
about and and leo
took some ideas from this i think you
can say that the
the uh series itself is in some respects
raising some some we don't necessarily
call them just tolstoy and
points but but some points about the
nature of
human history and endeavors and whether
individuals matter whether it's just
larger social developments and forces
so that's some some interesting um
side note stuff and we'll come back to
who he likes in in just a bit
i want to continue on with the story so
you know china is involved with this
space race they actually launched a
satellite by the time
that uh lutsi shin was
seven years old in 1970 by the way
they're they're they're trying to launch
it before japan
can launch theirs right so it's not just
like
opposing the russians and the americans
it's also
rivalry with with japan and so you know
liu tsushin
um encounters sci-fi speculative fiction
in 1976
mao zedong dies and um
his successor deng is going to start you
know changing things within china
and china is going to become much more
like the country that we know it as
today politically and and socially
um in high school liu starts
writing science fiction stories and you
know i do want to say
something that comes from an interesting
interview somebody asked him well why'd
you write science fiction he could have
written all sorts of stuff and he says
i only wrote science fiction i started
with science fiction and i ended up
being a science fiction
writer i started as a big fan of science
fiction
and in that sense i might be part of the
first generation of chinese writers who
engaged with science fiction
self-consciously which means we wanted
to become
science fiction writers as such and then
he goes on
and he says i want to clarify the
differences between the fans
of science fiction and the writers of
science fiction
i was a big fan of science fiction and
that was a new subculture in china i was
part of the first generation of
self-conscious
fans of science fiction but science
fiction writers of course
existed way before i started my work but
i think in terms of a
subculture of science fiction we were
the first generation
that generated that kind of
self-consciousness this is from the
public books
interview that he did and i think that's
that's quite important you know he
was part of uh this this
wave of appreciation and discussion
and engagement and and sort of diy
produce it yourself
science fiction early on and we can say
that there's subsequent waves
after that so
he starts writing these stories in in
high school
and he continues writing eventually in
1981 he's going to enroll
in the north china university of water
resources and electrical power he'll go
on to to earn an engineering degree and
work as an engineer
for quite a long time until about 2012
when he
is able to you know devote himself to
writing
full-time after he graduates he worked
in the
nyang zi guan power plant
and you know is is uh continuing to read
continuing to write continuing to
to develop um so he's living a kind of
i don't want to say double life in part
because they're really quite
integrated together in many respects
right so he um would start publishing
his work in science fiction world which
is
one of the main publication let's say
forums in in chinese science fiction
and he's got shorter works in there from
1999
onward he writes the novel
or publishes the novel china 2185
in 1989 so that's you know really
kind of early compared to some of his
his other works
then he writes some other novels he's
writing mostly short things
until the the 2000s he writes
the devil's bricks in 2002 the supernova
era
in 2003 ball lightning in 2004
and then finally this trilogy comes out
in
2006 for three body problem
2008 for the dark forest and
2010 for death's end
and he he actually earns a number of
awards he's nominated for many more
awards than he receives
but the awards that he does get 2006 he
wins
the galaxy award in china in 2015 the
the three body problem earns a hugel
award which he has his translator except
for him
2017 locus award for
deaths and and i think i i would imagine
the one that he's probably the most
proud of
is the 2018 award that he wins
arthur c clarke for imagination in
service
to society and boy that it really tells
you a lot i mean it really does map on
to arthur c
clarke the question that we have to ask
is
what's going on with leo c shin's
writings is there
a service to society in
being a science fiction author and i
think that's one of the questions that
we can
raise here i do want to mention a few
other things
in terms of this as we sort of shift
gears
towards the writing itself um
he tells us going back to the the
authors i like ken liu's work can you as
his translator
of the the these particular volumes
he's created a new science fictional
aesthetic that combines the restraint
depth and refinement of eastern culture
with the expansive imagination of modern
science fiction
i'm also a big fan of ted chiang whose
tower of babylon is among the most
powerful pieces
of science fiction i've ever read i also
enjoy works by robert sawyer ray
bradbury neil gaiman and paulo
uh baki galupi so
you know there's there's a number of
different authors that he is
not necessarily engaging with uh in the
sense of like drawing their stuff in but
who he he says that he enjoys
and and i i think that's um here we go
there's
there's a couple things that are are
important i think coming out of
interviews
that are worth um looking at here he
says
this is in the vocal interview when i
was just a reader of science fiction
what attracted me most to the science
fiction genre
was the multitude of imagined worlds it
had created which expanded the narrow
breadth
of my life let's pause on that for a
minute that's a very interesting idea
what is it that we get out of reading
science fiction
fantasy weird tales um even you know
reading the great literature
like the iliad and the odyssey we get
exposed to
other worlds that we ourselves could
never
actually experience or you know maybe we
could but it's
so many things that have to come
together just right for that to be the
case and i think we can also say this
about
really good sci-fi tv and movies as well
uh maybe even radio shows from back in
the day i don't i don't know
so he goes on and he says now that i've
become a science fiction
writer myself world building has become
a
primary direction for writing so world
building
is something quite important for him
at other points lucy shin is going to
talk about the the
importance of the human imagination and
that
imagination might be something that will
never be able to be
captured even by the the best ai
so that that's a very interesting idea
as well
coming back to this i mentioned that he
got involved in a bit of controversy
and it it it really is an important
controversy and kind of leads in nicely
to the the world
that he's he's writing in which is um
particularly in the beginning of these
these stories is so
dominated by um china-u.s
rivalry right so
the the adaptation of these these
volumes this trilogy
has been underway for a while
and netflix was in the process and may
still be in the process
of bringing out um you know an
adaptation of it now whether the
adaptation is going to be any good or
not
uh that remains to be seen the the two
show runners who did george r martin's
song of ice and fire and you know
essentially by
by season four we're way off book and
managing to botch it up
for a variety of reasons that we can we
can talk about at other points
i'm not sure that they're going to be
the best adapters of something
like this because the issues about you
know
the psychological versus sociological
approach that applied to the
game of thrones slash song of ice and
fire definitely
apply just as much to these novels
they're not so
character driven as such but much more
big ideas
movements chronicling things social
forces driven
in any case where the controversy
actually arose
is that um liutsy shin gave a extensive
interview in the new yorker in 2019
and he was asked about a number of
different topics some of which were
political
and one of which was the hot button
issue
that that raised the controversy and
it's about the uyghurs
in west china and xinjiang province if
you don't know
about them they are people who has been
there for
quite a long time at one time they were
a very important
uh transmitter of of buddhism eventually
many of them became
muslims and in western china
there's a lot of things that are being
done to them put being put into
concentration camps
you know effectively being forced out of
their
their their places many of them have
just essentially disappeared
um you know ways of of trying to
wean them away re-educate is the term uh
from from islam and there's a lot of
back and forth things there has been
some
terrorism there's also been some
terrorizing of the uyghur population
kind of similar to what
china has done with uh tibet as well
so this is a very controversial issue
and
um liu you know took took the position
that well
you know i think that um
we we have to be very careful in
condemning anything
you know you don't want these people
like setting off bombs and all that and
so
you can you can read the interview
yourself and see precisely what he said
that drew some fire from
five republican senators who then wrote
netflix saying that liu
merely parrots communist
chinese communist party ccp propaganda
and saying maybe they shouldn't be
associated with this netflix said well
you know we're not endorsing
these ideas we're just focusing on on
the the thing
and liu himself you know has said that
i'm not really political
i'm just telling stories um can he
completely get away with that it's it's
kind of tough to tell but that's that's
what he sticks with
is his story so we'll see what happens
with that going forward
that's probably enough about biography
there are a few things that i want to
get into
when it comes to
the specific works themselves their
origins and then we'll talk about
world building so he tells us in the in
a vice interview that the three body
problems started out as a short story
but later expanded in my mind like a
plant and grew
over time the story is set in a complex
universe and comprises many ideas
especially relating to the meaning of
humans
and aliens
in a future conditional interview a
little bit uh
broader picture that we're getting here
he says
i write science fiction because i love
science and i want to give the beauty of
science literary expression
ideas about science and technology thus
form the core of my stories
but i do think there's a difference
between science fictional thinking
and scientific thinking the science
portrayed in science fiction is mixed
with a large dose of imaginative
speculation
and is no longer strictly speaking
science at all but a
fictional projection of science that's
what you call scientific details are
really
science fictional details nice nice
distinction to make there isn't
it and then he says for example the
initial
inspiration for writing the three-body
problem came from a paper about the
three-body problem
in classical mechanics which involves
the motion of three bodies
under mutual gravitational attraction
and
is unpredictable under current
mathematics and physics
i read the paper and suddenly thought
what if the three bodies
were three sons how would intelligent
life on one of the planets
in such a system develop this was a good
science fictional idea
based on solid science but evocative of
interesting stories
but to go back to real science we have
not to date discovered any trinary star
systems in which the stars move
in this chaotic manner so you know again
where he's responding in some way to
that question that all
authors at one point or another get
asked where do you get your ideas from
well here's where i get my ideas from
i like science i want to talk about it i
find
in many places he talks about the beauty
of physics or mathematics
and he he's finding ways to
inject this into writing
another uh thing in future conditionally
says i have to come up with a new
speculative idea
that moves me profoundly when i'm
writing for example the unpredictable
emotion of three sons
and the civilization that would arise in
such a planetary system now here's where
we get to some interesting
world building stuff i plan out a story
around this seed
right so the world building is
you might say
thinking not quite about like the
languages or anything like that but
what would it be like what is what is
the the premise
and then a bit of plot can come in and
then he says
finally i create the characters to serve
the story
so he doesn't start with characters and
then get the plot
from them like for example ursula k le
guin sometimes says that she does
you know letting her characters talk to
her ate george rr martin
kind of hints at doing that himself
although he does a lot of plotting
um with liu it's it's it's on the other
end it's like well what is the universe
like
and then what's going on here that's
plot and then who are the people who are
doing it and he says my method of
composition
inevitably leads to stories in which the
speculative idea is the core
the kind of stories that is seen as
appealing to hardcore fans
so the characters i mean there are some
really good compelling characters in
here
but the characters come out of that that
hopper you might say at another
interview
with vocal he said somebody had said is
this character you
you know or does it represent some of
your ideas and he says the characters in
my novels have little to do
with my own life when i was portraying
these characters
i rarely put myself into them they're
more like some kinds of signs or symbols
and their character development is
mainly dictated by the need of the
the story isn't that an interesting way
to put it
as a matter of fact you could say that
he manages to build something like that
in with the fairy tales
that are told that play a very important
role
in the final final book right death's
end the stories that that end up
being used to convey information about
the trisolarians
and about earth's predicament
you could say that that he's he's kind
of replicating in a certain way
his own process later on
in the public books interview he says 90
of my efforts are about telling a
creative
compelling story the focus is always on
my striving
as writer towards compelling
storytelling if there
is some message in my work it's either
something i see in hindsight once the
work is finished
or the interpretation of my beloved
critics he was asked you know
are your stories like you know are they
allegories or what are we supposed to
get from these stories right
and that's that's pretty typical and he
says is there a thematic allegorical
drive is there an allegorical message
i want to convey i don't think so he
doesn't say
no definitely not he just says i don't
think so i'm always fascinated and
surprised by how rich the interpretation
of my work has become
so many rich implications of my work are
never in my mind but they've been
produced by the interpreters right
kind of a he's not really a post-modern
as
as such but it's it's sort of a typical
thing the interpreter
creates a lot of the meaning um
it's there's another story that gets
told and i'm not sure exactly where it
is but
he was um
he took a test that was given about his
own stories
about how you're supposed to you know
figure out the meaning of what's going
on in some of his stories
and he flunked because he couldn't come
up with
the right answers according to what the
chinese educational establishment had
said about his
his own work um
there's one other thing that i found in
this public books interview that i
thought would be
kind of interesting as a launching point
he's he's he's asked about um science
fiction
and you know we might say
is there like a kind of science fiction
or is there a plurality of it
and he says my personal view is that
there should not be
just one single paradigm for science
fiction there should be
various kinds of science fiction
some writers will use science fiction or
elements of fantasy to allegorize
reality to be critical of reality and
represent and reflect upon reality
this kind of science fiction gained a
particular name in chinese chinese
critics like to label
it science fantasy realism as for me i'm
not interested in this approach
tradition or tenancy i'm not interested
in allegorizing criticizing representing
reality
for me the most valuable the most
precious part of science fiction
is that we can build a world entirely
based on
imagination so this goes back to that
question about well
you know the arthur c clarke award
for imagination in service to society
how does how does science fiction
actually
serve society does it do so through
allegorizing
you know does for example 1984 or
fahrenheit 451 do they present
us with okay avoid these sorts of models
or do
some of the mistakes that are being made
in
these novels do they show us how how to
avoid
making similar mistakes or is there
something else that's going
on something more complex something less
directly
one story allegorized to another story
a kind of cultivation that's that's
going on
he goes on and he says everything is
purely up in the air that kind of
fantastic imagination
is the reason why i love science fiction
here's where we get to that thing i
referenced earlier i remember one
historian said that the difference
between humans
and other species is that we have the
ability to use our imaginations to build
something
actually given the role that imagination
has played in our evolution as a species
this creation of the non-actual might be
the only ability in which we can surpass
artificial intelligence isn't that an
interesting
idea there that maybe
artificial intelligence let's do a
little bit of you know the mat
uh philosophical thematics right here i
realized that i you know
i was going to do that later but this is
kind of top of mind for me
since i'm teaching rene descartes once
again descartes
in his discourse on method in the fifth
part
he talks about how
animals and mechanisms and human beings
are different
and he's he's been confronted with
you know mechanisms that seem to mimic
human beings and he thinks of
animals as essentially being like that
now maybe he's wrong
maybe there's a rationality maybe
there's a mind in animals that he
couldn't discern
we won't worry about that let's just
think about humans and machines
he says that you know machines can
probably be made
so that they would do things that human
beings do
even better than human beings and we
might think about how the you know
great a.i can be to human chess grand
master
but the problem is that great human that
great
artificial intelligence can't tie its
own shoes
and can't cognize about its own circuits
whereas even if the chess grandmaster
walks away or even some schlub like me
walking in playing and getting beaten in
like five moves
i can still do all these things i can
you know proverbially
walk and chew gum at the same time or
smoke and joke and
drink coke as they say in my family i'm
not sure where that expression came from
the fact that we can take on these
things these expressions
is also really important too descartes
thought that
this no matter how far the ai advances
it's never really going to be able to do
everything quite like a human being
does and liu is
is saying something about imagination
here descartes wanted to think it had to
do with the intellect
but descartes also recognized that our
intellect is almost
never free of the imagination as a
matter of fact
in a letter he says you can probably do
pure intellection maybe one hour out of
a month
the rest of the time it's this mind-body
connection
and there can you know they're they're
infusing each other i can't quite
explain how this happens he says
but there's there's definitely something
there so that's an interesting
theme to think about let's let's delve
into world building now
so the narrative world of this
this trilogy is our universe
obviously he's not going to depict the
entirety of the universe or the
these books would be a lot thicker uh as
a matter of fact they might not even
fit into a room so there's always a lot
of you know sketching things out but
this this is taking place
within the world that we know a world
whose whose rules laws processes
are illuminated by research into the
natural sciences
whose actions by by human beings can be
illuminated to some degree
by research into the social sciences by
history
and by the humanities you might say
in in general it's also a universe
in which other beings other rational
beings or
other intelligent beings let's call them
i mean they are rational
uh maybe rational beyond our rationality
even do exist
and you know the title of the second
book the dark
forest describes the
the universe that we
are just little beginner babies
in uh and there's all these other
species out there
we just we're not seeing them and we'll
talk about that as a philosophical theme
in a bit there is a species that that
plays a major role throughout
most of these stories there's some other
species
later on that that can play a role as
well but they don't play that big of a
role
and that is the trisolarians so we
should talk about them
and you know some people have summarized
the book about
being about planet a and planet b or
planet x and planet y
so one of them is earth and one of them
is trisolaris and it's called trisolaris
because there's
there's three suns and that's that's why
it's the
three body problem in the first place
there's also a game a computer
well it's not just a game it's the whole
second world
virtual reality in which people can
experience something
like what the trisolarian world
is like human beings and then can
communicate with each other
as well and so the trisolarians
um they
are living in a star system that's only
four
light years away from our own and it's
one that
is quite dangerous dangerous
not just for individuals but for
their entire species for life within the
system as a matter of fact there have
been other planets and the other planets
have been
sucked into some of these these stars
and because of the weird ways in which
the stars rotate
it can be too cold it can be too hot
fortunately trisolarians can be
desiccated they can have all the water
taken out of them and then be you know
revived later on
and there there are different kind of
beings than than we are at the beginning
they don't know how to deceive
right they they don't have that that
trait that we human beings
man kids learn it early on don't they
about how to
how to trick people or how to say things
that aren't true
in part because they display their minds
to each other and they live in a rather
totalitarian society
but they are certainly beyond us in
terms of technology
and we end up sending a signal that they
they receive and now they know that
there's life here on earth
and they begin to interact with
human beings now how can they they do
that
well it takes messaging messaging back
and forth but they also
build these um essentially you
you know they've been called you know
micro computers because they're they're
a single um
uh you know single bit of matter
that has been um
turned into this this massive uh
integrated circuit
machine the cell phones right and they
they're unfolded into all these
dimensions and then folded back and they
can be shot at
earth and although you know takes the
ships from
from trisolaris hundreds of years to get
there
this um single you know proton can be
sent there and then start doing its its
stuff communicating with human beings
um it's in real time you might say
and so they think of them as having a
a lock on earth and they they start you
know
monkeying around with our own
development
making scientists um have
you know discrep discrepancies in their
readings when it comes to basic
physics research and particle
accelerators and so
they stop our development short
and they begin to assemble a fleet
that is going to leave their system and
come here
and colonize earth meanwhile on
earth there are human beings who are in
contact with them
and are essentially betraying the the
planet
to align themselves with the
trisolarians one of whom they call the
lord
and um you know they they come in a
couple different factions you could say
um and mean at the same time china the
united
states the europeans are figuring out
what's what's going on
at least in some of the intelligence and
military agencies
and they're trying to engage in some
sort of
counter response and you know the the
idea here
is we're not in a friendly universe
we're actually in
as we've discovered a dark forest where
we probably shouldn't have sent
out a signal we were kind of naive and
dumb to do
so and now what are we going to do as
the
human race and so then we can talk about
when it comes to the world building and
the
settings we can talk about a future
history being
sketched out developed out by lyutzi
shin
and there's a number of different eras
that are very
convenient ways of conceptualizing this
right
so there's the um common era before
we're
in touch with trisolaris and that leads
you know all the way up to the chinese
cultural revolution
and and all of these times and then
there's the crisis era
once humanity finds out that it's it's
not
alone in the universe some people are
very enthusiastic oh yeah
it's great you know there's there's
other life and then we realize that they
want to
kill us that they see us as bugs who are
in their way
and maybe they can be reasoned with
maybe they can't be reasoned with
and so then the human beings
engage in a number of different projects
they begin building a space
fleet for example they start that you
know developing
space elevators to carry things into
space they
they develop as much as they can along
different lines and there's all sorts of
substories that are being told
fascinating
you know bits here and there where like
this advance happens because this person
does
these things and i would say that the
the
most important parts of this crisis era
one of one of it is is the wall facer
project
right wall facers are the people
who are are supposed to
be entrusted with coming up with the the
new ideas
part of the problem is these these cell
phones these these super computers
can basically see everything that's
going on but they can't read
human minds so four human beings are
chosen
to come up with the strategic responses
by the un
because now you know we've actually got
a a unified
uh response to all this craziness
they're being chosen to come up with
ideas
and then somehow you know carry out
strategic thinking
on their own but which will be
implemented they're given lots of
resources
and the one who actually survives
well into the process is uh leo g
who is kind you know the other wall
facers it makes sense why
uh they're chosen they're very important
people luigi is kind of a
you know kind of schmuck really he uh
you know
he does work but he just does enough
work to get by he's kind of a hedonist
he does have a great depth of character
as we discover in there
and so there's that going on and then
there's also this staircase
project going on which culminates
in sending out a human being
a human brain a human being preserved
just as their brain
out to the trisolarians to try to carry
out diplomacy with them with the idea
that they'll be able to you know
resuscitate this brain
and turn it into a living human being
and that
is uh unt ming
and it also involves another major
character who's found through the the
rest of the novels
um so that's the crisis era and there
it's all about the human responses how
are they going to deal with this sort of
stuff
ultimately the human fleet will
be destroyed as these these two probes
come into the the uh area you know into
the solar system
they're made out of a kind of matter
at least coated with a kind of matter
that
uses the strong you know force and
just makes them you know impenetrable
and they can destroy just about anything
so they destroy almost all of the
human space fleet some of the space
fleet is able to
very few of them are able to escape and
then we move into the deterrence era
[Music]
luo g is is resuscitated
after one of his seemingly rather exotic
plans about putting a curse on a star
uh turns out to work basically he
reveals
the location of you know intelligent uh
aliens on on this this star
uh and it gets nailed by by what we call
black forest uh
response and destroyed the sun is
destroyed and now the tricelerians like
holy crap um
you know we've got to avoid this and the
you know the it's modeled after what was
called mad
mutually uh assured destruction so
uh lugee becomes what's called the sword
holder he
ha he's able to send out at any moment
a pulse to the universe that says um
tricelerians are over there and human
beings are over here
if if the tricelerians do invade then
we'll just you know have everything
destroyed and that that works for for
quite a while
and there's actually a lot of cultural
exchange at this point between the
tri-solarians
and human beings they even like make our
television shows and stuff like that and
there's a lot of
physical science progress that's made
and and there's there's other problems
along the way as well
now when cheng shin becomes the
new sword holder she doesn't have the
resolve
that um leo g does and the
trisolarians destroy the
transmitters that would send out this
this pulse
and human beings now are at the mercy of
these
these aliens who are going to be
arriving soon
and so in the post-deterrence era the
tricelerians are preparing
earth for colonization and they in fact
try to make all of the people of earth
gather into australia as a reservation
and
you know based on on mars for the
fleets and and people who are out in the
solar system
then there's an another era when a
broadcast is able to um
show the other aliens in the universe
where the trisolaris system is
and they suffer a a dark forest attack
their son one of the three sons is
destroyed
and that destroys their planet and then
the tricelerians
you know bank away and they're going
somewhere else in
in the universe um now the the the
you know worry is not so much about the
tricelerians
it's more about wow this whole other you
know set of aliens in the universe
when are they going to realize that
we're here and launch a single attack to
destroy
the earth which does in fact happen
there's an entire galactic network a
bureaucracy that handles
that sort of thing as we find out in
death's end
and so human beings once again are like
thinking well what do we do
you know and there's there's a couple
different ideas one is to create
they they they figure out that
um that
near light speed ships can
um you know be launched
and that they change the nature of space
that they go through and so one
possibility is to create
essentially like a shell around the
solar system
in which human beings would would live
the rest of their
their life and they would never be able
to get into the rest of the universe but
they would be safe
from those those attacks another
possibility
uh would be to try to have you know
lights
essentially light speed um travel and to
get the hell out of dodge while you can
the third is to engage in the bunkers
which are these cities
behind planets like
neptune and uranus and and
you know jupiter pluto and to have
humanity survive
on those and leave the earth more or
less barren
it turns out that that would work
against the kind of attack that
destroyed trisolaris but it doesn't work
against the other kind of attack
which effectively turns
three-dimensional space
into two dimensions and so then that
leads into the final
era where only a few human beings
relatively speaking have actually
managed to escape and survive the galaxy
era where there's there's human
survivors from the very few ships that
got away
and um who've colonized other places
um and um you know uh cheng shin
and and a few other people as well who
got away on on that ship
and this is spanning a a vast amount of
time the other thing that i do have to
mention
in here is that cryogenics is used to
[Applause]
allow people essentially to traverse not
just space but
but time and so you know by the end
of the book we're really quite at the
end of the three book series
we're very far into the future
and human beings have gone through a lot
of important transformations
and you know a lot of events have taken
place much has been lost
much has been just forgotten and that's
the
universe that the utsishin
is creating before going on to explore
what is really the
premier philosophical theme of this
trilogy the dark
forest itself and all that goes along
with it
there is another let's call it broadly
philosophical
theme that i want to explore
and this is coming from the public books
interview there's a long
section of dialogue between
leo cecin and the the
interviewer about the nature of
particular let's call them disciplines
meaning by this
the sort of old-fashioned philosophical
approach
to calling some things science and some
things
other things and trying to figure out
where philosophy actually
fits in with them and we can expand this
as well to
literature science fiction as as lu shin
does
and so i think we can read a lot of that
into these
books so um
[Music]
if we uh look at this this interview
he says let me focus on my philosophical
influences
and he says this as a response to being
asked about
philosophical and religious influences
he says listen i'm an atheist so i don't
have religious influences
to think about although religion does
sometimes play a role in these stories
let me focus on my philosophical
influences
philosophy has a profound impact on me
that's because in my view if we compare
science and philosophy
which one is closer to science fiction
that's a really interesting
question isn't it and you know you could
say well
it depends on on what philosophy or
we're talking about i mean philosophy
plays around with thought experiments
engages
in hypotheticals counterfactuals
whatever you want to call them
uses the imagination to go beyond the
realm
of the the existing or the actual
but you can also say well science does
that too doesn't it i mean
scientists come up with hypotheses and
then have to
think about what would it take to
actually be able to test this
and they have to take data that they
they get and
figure out interesting interpretations
of the data
and there's a lot of back and forth and
that that's quite true
but where is lutz's shin gonna come down
on he says well philosophy is actually
closer and he gives an explanation he
says
if we take science as a world view
according to this world view there's
only one single
image of the world but philosophy is
entirely different
every philosopher has his or her own
world view and every worldview is so
different from the others
if an alien came from outside this
universe
they would be totally puzzled by the
debates between our philosophers this
alien would be puzzled
because it doesn't seem like the
philosophers are talking about the same
world now he might be exaggerating there
he might be overplaying his hand because
obviously if every philosopher has his
or her own
world view then none of them would
actually be able to communicate
with each other if they were like
totally incommensurable totally
different from each other
there is a significant difference though
you can talk about the sciences and this
is another way of thinking about it as
being convergent disciplines
there are times when within sciences
there are rival theories
working right and and the more that we
get into
um applied sciences like
the more that we get into say like
medicine the more that there can be
alternative approaches
that due to the complexity of things
aristotle himself noted this
right the complexity of things makes it
difficult to generalize about
particulars
but in general the sciences the natural
sciences
and even the social sciences and
mathematics which he's going to talk
about later are convergent in that
there's there's one
main point of view that is is the right
point of view at least the right point
of view at this point in time you might
discard it entirely later like the ether
right that everyone believed in just 150
years ago or you know
uh there could be paradigm shifts but
it's a shift from one paradigm
to another um it's a little bit
different once we get into the social
sciences
um you know sometimes there's conversion
sometimes there isn't
and there's usually a lot of different
theories floating around out there think
about
you know psychology think about even
economics which
is probably the the most um enamored
of pretending that it's a real science
uh in in many respects like
like the the natural sciences
but then when we get into the humanities
things are are quite different and
philosophy is one of the humanities now
we can also say there's been this desire
in philosophy and not just among you
know like recent analytic philosophers
who wanted to subordinate philosophy to
science
um but even in people like kant you know
you think about
emanuel kant and his his you know saying
we've made no progress throughout the
history of philosophy i'm going to
finally set things right
once and for all with my critiques and
then everything will be you know
hunky-dory afterwards it's just
kind of filling things in there's this
tendency in philosophy
to want it to be a convergent science
and
instead you know lucinda's saying no no
philosophy is not really like that
and if you look at the history of
philosophy
there's no one right approach to the
history of philosophy
even what you do confront when you like
delve into actual
systems and and for example like
platonism right you can read all of
plato's dialogues and piece something
together
and that's like the tip of the iceberg
of platonism
because then you can go on and see what
later platonists who are thinking about
these things in very deep ways and also
responding to other schools
made of these these things and you know
so if you don't read plutarch you don't
really know platonism if you don't read
albinus and uh por you know porphyry
and platynus you don't really know
platonism
as a a tradition and you can say the
same thing with aristotelianism you know
there's aristotle who's great
and then there's let's say alexander of
aphrodisias right
in his commentaries which are quite
innovative
stuff and and each of these is is really
quite different and
is lutz's shin right in saying that that
each philosopher is seeing or each maybe
philosophical approach or tradition of
seeing a different world
i think he's right about that it is a
world that is
shared to some extent but different
different aspects of it are being
emphasized so they have a different
metaphysics they have they have a
different ethics they have a different
psychology and that's that's quite true
so now imagine this this uh
thought experiment of aliens arriving at
this world
and seeing these debates between
philosophers
maybe if they don't have something like
that in their
own you know background history
way of doing things they would in fact
be puzzled
it might be the case though that they
couldn't really be
fully intelligent life lacking that
i'll leave that out there so let's come
back to this so he says in this regard
philosophy is closest to science fiction
because different writers of science
fiction are striving to create different
world images of social formation of
history of the universe
of course the way i'm influenced by
philosophers might be very different
than other people's pursuit of
philosophical insight so he's not saying
this this is the the take on philosophy
as such and he says
for others they may want to find the
truth in a philosophical discourse now
this is interesting he's not interested
in
the truth in a philosophical discourse
he says something that almost sounds
kind of chestertonian
like like you know gk chesterton every
philosophical discourse for me will be
judged by one standard
which is whether it's interesting
whether there's a
story to tell one really curious outcome
some radically opposing philosophical
schools have an equal influence on me
for example idealism is of course so
vastly different from materialism but
for me they're both
sources of inspiration
so isn't that an interesting way of
looking at things
is it pragmatic yes but pragmatism is
ultimately oriented towards
truth if there is a truth here it's a
truth in the narrative it's a different
kind of truth
we might think of it as not you know
correspondence theory truth but rather
pragmatic theory truth or perhaps
heidegger's truth as
revealing alethea right which always
involves concealing i think that could
be
applied here quite well
now he goes on in the interview and
the person asks
says science can be a concept of
discourse it can refer to a discipline
of natural sciences but also a method it
means a worldview a way of thinking
this is important for science fiction
science is sometimes confused with
technology which creates
its own kind of world picture as an
engineer
as a science fiction writer living in
this post einsteinian technological
world what's your definition
of science and now lucid doesn't give a
definition of science he sidesteps the
issue
and he says this is indeed a very
complicated issue especially when it
comes to science's relation with
technology
first of all technology precedes science
way before the rise of modern science
there were so many technologies so many
technological innovations
today technology is deeply embedded in
the development of science so he sees
that as
a fundamental difference in our
contemporary world
science that's a glass ceiling for
technology
the degree of technological development
is predetermined by the advances of
science
now this plays a central role in in
these stories right
in the the three body problem the
trisolarians the
they use the cell phones these you know
proton micro computers that can control
things and and view things all over the
world
they use them essentially to stop our
scientific
development when it comes to fundamental
you know basic physics
by screwing up some of the experiments
that are going on and also trying to
drive the physicists themselves
insane to drive them into despair
that is is setting that glass ceiling
right there we could also think about
other you know developments
for example you know one of the key
ideas
that comes up is you know whether ai can
really
do the things that people predict it
will do you notice that there aren't any
any ais other than the cell phone who
who you know is this this robot who
essentially speaks for
the um trisolarian you know
the the ais that we talk about that like
you know siri on our phone are not real
ais
they're they're just you know there's
programs that are that are
essentially running along and doing
their interesting things but they don't
have
consciousness they don't have the
capacity to really do research or
anything like that
the advances in in computing are going
to be driven in part by by the sciences
as well
so he goes on and he says there's an
interesting paradoxical
interdependence between the two science
and technology
what is remarkably interesting is how
technology becomes so interconnected
with science
in the ancient greek world now is is
this entirely true
no but but it's a good story science
develops out of logic
and reason there's no reliance on
technology the big game changer
is galileo's method of doing experiments
in order to prove a theory than putting
theory back into experimentation now
people did experimentation before
galileo
and this is kind of an interesting tale
but there is a good point here
you can in fact develop
sciences without relying heavily on
technology
at least to certain degrees right you
can
also develop technology you know on its
own
uh in many respects without having to do
some sort of scientific study or
discourse about it
so here he goes on and he says this
reliance has become stronger and
stronger up until our time
the today the frontiers of physics are
totally conditioned on the developments
of technology
so if there's a glass ceiling in terms
of science
and then the technology rising to meet
it there's also a glass ceiling
in terms of the technology that's
available and then
you know the the science itself rising
to meet it
so he says this is unprecedented he
talks about a new particle accelerator
and he says
the information you can receive from
today's technological accelerator is
still
far far away for what you need for
experiments in the most advanced physics
so he says there's a poetic nickname for
this difference between technologies
capacities and the requirements of the
scientific question
a desert of physics then the
conversation turns towards mathematics
and the the questioner says
do you think of mathematics as among the
sciences or in a perpendicular relation
to them because mathematics doesn't need
that kind of empiricism
and this is this is quite true that
mathematics for a long time
could develop without necessarily the
other sciences
contributing or technology contributing
i don't know that that's actually
all that true today because we rely
on computers so much for some
branches of mathematics so he says
well it's kind of this is kind of
curious some people say mathematics
doesn't belong to science
even if we say mathematics is part of
science mathematics is an exceptional
case
because it doesn't rely on technology
following up on the science's reliance
on technology
i would like to point to a very
paradoxical phenomenon right now we can
see technology is based on the advances
of science
meanwhile science has to rely on
technology for verification
if there's ever been a time when this
circularity was good
when they supported each other's
development i would like to say
it was the early 20th century the golden
age of modern physics
what we have today might be instead a
vicious
circle that is science and technology
are mutually limited
by each other if we compare science to a
fruit tree those fruits that are within
our reach are already picked the more
most important the most pioneering
branches are totally beyond our
reach what can we do here's where
there's a shift taking place so we've
brought in now philosophy
literature and the other humanities
sciences
technology mathematics what can we do we
turn to the fields of information and
communication beyond information and
communication however
it seems to me that there's no
breakthrough in our
near future isn't that an interesting
thing to bring in now we have you know
something that seems to be like a social
science but it actually isn't it's
another
kind of discipline communication and
information
information literacy for example or
thinking about
communication processes semiotics as a
field
that's very promising and then the the
questionnaire says well what about
science fiction
could science fiction itself have a role
to play in changing this locked
relationship
perhaps just by offering a different way
of thinking about the two
and here's where lucy shin says
something really interesting
you've assigned a mission to science
fiction that is too sublime
i continue to see science fiction as
simply part of popular culture
if it can help readers open up their
horizon and inspire them to explore even
more that would be a huge success
already so he's setting the bar
deliberately
low for how science fiction would
contribute
to this this mass of the different
disciplines and their interrelations
which are always
human disciplines right always carried
out with each other now of course in the
stories
some of these are not just human
disciplines
technology science the tricelerians have
those they even have a certain kind of
you might say approach to philosophy
although they're kind of limited in that
communication
you might say is is uh there's too much
of it they can't lie to each other
easily because they communicate so
transparently so there's a lot of uh
interesting ideas here that that do play
a role
in a sort of subterranean way within
these works
the philosophical theme that you know so
many people have picked up on
and talked about when it comes to this
trilogy
is in the dark forest then we can call
it the the dark
forest theme and you find it laid out
in a essentially a philosophical
discourse
at the end of the dark forest that is
taking place between
the wall facer and sword holder
and scholar liu g very interesting
character
and then probably one of my favorite
characters of the book
uh she chiang the hard-boiled
police you know detective investigator
tough guy who admittedly says you know
listen i i don't know
all of this this stuff you know i'm i'm
just doing
my my part here but who ends up being a
very good friend to
uh leo g and lul is
has developed you know this this
discipline
that allows him to understand what's
going on out in the universe among
um aliens among among those who are not
us but let's just call them
civilizations and cultures intelligent
life forms
and this is a response to what's often
been called you know
the fair me paradox there's a lot of
discussion out there that you can look
up i'm not going to spend
too much time on that but the question
is well if there is intelligent life
out there why haven't we
been contacted by them why haven't we
seen traces of them you know we're
probably a relatively new form of life
in a new civilization
so there's probably galactic
civilizations that have been out there
for
for quite a long time and
there's this very important uh discourse
so
he i'm gonna i'm gonna read some of it
and and go over
some of it as well and he says okay i'm
going to lay this out for you
dashi big big she right that's that's
the guy's nickname
so he says we're going to set out two
axioms for cosmic civilization
first first axiom survival is the
primary need of civilization second
civilization continuously grows and
expands but the total matter in the
universe
remains constant and then he says well
what can you derive from these little
things the same way that you can figure
out an
entire case from a bullet or a drop of
blood cosmic sociology is able to
describe a complete picture of galactic
and cosmic civilization
from these two axioms that's what
science is like the cornerstone of every
discipline is quite simple
so he brings this up because they're
talking about the battle of darkness
which we'll come back to
in just a bit but he says would you
believe me if i said that starship
earth was a microcosm of cosmic
civilization
and dashi says no starship earth lacked
resources like parts and fuel but the
universe doesn't it's too big and he
says no
no you're wrong the universe is big but
life
is bigger this is very interesting from
a
philosophical perspective right life
in a certain sense now what is life life
is the capacity to self-organize life is
the capacity to respond life is the
capacity to build and reproduce
itself it says the second axiom tells us
this
the amount of matter in the universe
remains constant
but life grows exponentially
exponentials are the devils of
mathematics
if there's a microscopic bacterium in
the ocean that divides once every half
hour
its descendants will fill the entire
ocean in the space of a few days
so long as there are sufficient
nutrients don't let humanity and
trisolaris give you a false impression
these two civilizations are tiny but
they're only in their infancy
once a civilization passes a certain
technological threshold
the expansion of life through the
universe is frightening
for instance take humanity's present
navigation speed in a million years
earth civilization could fill the galaxy
and a million years is a short time
measured against the universe
so what does this mean this means that
if a civilization is successful it will
spread
now on a you know our frame of reference
it's very slow
how it's happening but it will
inevitably spread and take over
the entire galaxy so he says
well the universe looks empty we haven't
seen any other
alien life apart from trisolaris and so
luigi then
you know is representing things with
with cigarettes and he says okay to
illustrate the problem we need to
establish the most elementary model of
cosmic civilization
these two balls of flame the cigarette
ends represent the two civilized planets
the universe is made up of only these
two planets
apart from them there's nothing else
erase all the surroundings
can you locate that feeling says yeah
that's an easy feeling in a dark place
like this let's call these two civilized
worlds your civilization and my
civilization
they're separated by a great distance
you can detect that i exist but you
don't know any details
i'm completely ignorant of your presence
so
that's fine and he says now we need to
define
two concepts benevolence and malice
between civilizations
these words themselves aren't very
rigorous in a scientific context so
we've got to restrict their meaning
benevolence means not taking the
initiative to attack and eradicate other
civilizations malice is the opposite he
says well that's a low bar for
benevolence
and that's true so it's essentially
malice and non-malice
consider your options for dealing with
me remember that the axioms of cosmic
civilization should be kept in mind
through the process as well as the
distance scale and the environment of
space
i could choose to communicate with you
if you do that
you should be aware of the price you'll
pay you'll have exposed your existence
to me
right in the universe that's no small
thing he says well there's different
degrees of exposure
the strongest form of exposure is when i
know your precise interstellar
coordinates next is when i know your
general direction
weakest is when i only know of your
existence but even the weakest form of
exposure
makes it possible for me to search for
you because since you've detected my
existence i know i'll be able to find
you
it's only a matter of time from the
standpoint of technological development
and that is what they discuss
in in you know in the works but
i could still take the risk to talk to
you if you're malicious then it's my bad
luck but if you're benevolent we could
have further exchanges and
ultimately be united into a benevolent
civilization and then he says
that's right dashi now we're at the crux
let's return to the axioms even if i'm a
benevolent civilization
can i determine at the start of our
communication whether or not
you are also benevolent and dashi says
no
that would violate the first axiom so
once i've received your message what
should i do
naturally you ought to determine whether
i'm benevolent
or malicious malicious and you eradicate
me beloved benevolent and we can
continue communicating
he said that's fine in on earth but not
out in the universe
we'll introduce an important new concept
and this is this is the
really the killer the chain of suspicion
so what is it if you think i'm
benevolent that's not a reason to feel
safe because according to the first
axiom
a benevolent civilization can't predict
any other civilization is benevolent
you don't know whether i think you're
benevolent or malicious
next even if you know that i think
you're benevolent
and i also know that you think i'm
benevolent i don't know what you think
about
what i think about what you're thinking
about me
it's convoluted isn't it he says this is
just the third level
but the logic goes on indefinitely
and he says that's the chain of
suspicion it's something that you don't
see on earth
why humanity's shared species cultural
similarities interconnected ecosystem
close distances mean in this environment
the chain of suspicion
will only extend a level or two before
it's resolved through communication
but in space the chain of suspicion can
be very long
so then he refers back to the battle of
darkness and
we'll come back to that so he jumping to
this he says
so the outcome is the same regardless of
whether we're benevolent civilizations
or malicious
civilizations that's right that's the
most important aspect of the chain of
suspicion
it's unrelated to the civilization's own
morality and social structure
it's enough to think of every
civilization as the points at the end of
a chain
regardless of whether civilizations
are internally benevolent or malicious
when they enter the web form by chains
of suspicions they're all identical
it becomes a sort of games theory except
a very complicated one
he says um and so dashie says well okay
but if you're weaker than me that you're
not a threat to me so i can always
communicate with you right if i'm a
higher civilization
he says and then uh lulu says
that wouldn't work either here's the
second important concept the
technological explosion
um human civilization has five thousand
years of history life on earth
might be as much as a few billion years
old but modern technology was developed
over the course of 300 years
on the scale of the universe that's not
development it's an explosion the
potential for technological leaps
is the explosive buried within every
civilization
if it's lit by some internal or external
factor it goes off with a bang
he says there's no reason why humanity
should be the fastest of
all cosmic civilizations so what's the
upshot of this
maybe there are other civilizations
whose technological
you know explosions are even more sudden
i'm weaker than you but once i've
received your message and know of your
existence the chain of suspicion is
established between us and
if at any time i experience a
technological explosion that puts me far
ahead of you i'm stronger than you
so that means that everybody is a threat
to everybody there's no way around it
in in this this model that's been
put forward which as it turns out in the
book
well the series is the case there is a
galactic civilization that ends up
wiping out earth
for precisely this sort of reason
we're going to go on a little bit more
and then we'll come to talk about you
know the the
battle in the darkness and and thomas
hobbes so here's the central model that
that lou provides he says
a hunter in a dark force stalking with
baited breath
notices that a piece of bark has been
stripped from a tree in front of him
on the eye-catching bit of white wood
that's been revealed as a position in
the forest written in characters all
hunters can recognize
what will he think about that location
he's not going to imagine that someone
laid out supplies from there
out of all the possibilities the most
likely one is that the blaze is
informing everyone there's live prey at
that location that needs to be
eliminated
doesn't matter what motivated someone to
leave the mark what's important is that
the dead hand
has stretched the nerves of the dark
forest to the breaking point and what is
the dark force he says
the universe is like a dark forest every
civilization is an
armed hunter stalking through the trees
like a ghost
gently pushing aside branches that block
the path trying to tread without sound
even breathing is done with care the
hunter has to be careful
because everywhere in the forest our
stealthy hunters like him
if he finds another life another hunter
an angel or demon a delicate infant or
tottering old man a fairy or demigod
there's only one thing he can do open
fire
and eliminate them in this forest hell
is other people
an eternal threat is any life that
exposes its own existence
will be swiftly wiped out this
is the picture of cosmic civilization
it's the explanation for the fermi
paradox and then he goes on and says
there's a stupid child called humanity
who has built a bonfire and is standing
beside his shouting here i am
here i am so that's that's uh
quite a a problem later on in death's
end
it gets even worse and there's this
discussion
um here we go
this is um uh guan
yifan and um
uh chang shin talking and it says
um here we go
the reality of the universe is not
something to envy
darkness only darkness and then um uh
chang shin says do you mean the dark
forest state what we've just talked
about here
and he says no for us the dark forest
state is all important but it's just a
detail of the cosmos if you think about
the cosmos as a great battlefield
dark forest strikes are nothing more
than snipers shooting at the careless
messengers mess men etc
in the grand scheme of the battle
they're nothing you've not seen what a
true
interstellar war is like she says have
you
we've and he says we've caught a few
glimpses but most things we know are
just guesses
do you really want to know the more that
you possess of this kind of knowledge
the less light remains in your heart and
so she says my heart is already
completely dark
i want to know and so he says
and more than six centuries after liu g
had fallen through into ice
that lake another dark veil holding the
truth of our universe was lifted before
the gaze of one of the only survivors of
earth civilization
yiphon asked why don't you tell me what
the most powerful weapon for a
civilization possessing almost
infinite technological prowesses don't
think of this as a technical problem
think philosophy chang shin pondered for
a while and struggled to shake her head
i don't know
your experiences should give you a hint
what had she experienced
she had seen how a cruel attacker could
lower the dimensions of space by one and
destroy a solar system what are
dimensions
the universal laws of physics
he goes on and says that's right the
universal laws of physics are the most
terrifying weapons
and also the most effective defenses
whether it's by the milky way or the
andromeda galaxy at the scale of the
local galactic group or the virgo
supercluster
those warring civilizations possessing
godlike technology will not hesitate to
use the universal laws of physics as
weapons there are many laws that can be
manipulated into weapons
but most commonly the focus is on
spatial dimensions and the speed of
light
so you know that that that goes on
isn't that an interesting concept there
now who is the author that gets brought
up all the time
in relation to this well it's thomas
hobbs right and if you remember your
intro to philosophy class or political
science class or something like that
in chapter 13 hobbes describes the
natural condition of mankind
as concerning their felicity and misery
and
he says that we're in the state of
nature when we're not subject to some
sort of
sovereign some sort of you know power
that can compel
all of us when we're not recognizing
what he's going to lay out later
as the laws of nature rational laws that
we can understand that allow us to live
and prosper then we're going to be in a
war of
all against all and what is the reason
for this
well it's our very rationality itself
he says that in the nature of man we
find three principal causes of quarrel
competition diffidence
glory right the first make people
invade for gain the second for safety
that's the one that plays the key role
here the third for reputation
the first use violence to make
themselves masters of other men's
persons wives children and cattle
the second to defend them the third for
trifles as a word a smile a different
opinion
and any other signs of undervalue either
direct in their persons or by reflection
of their kindred
their friends their nation their
profession or their name hereby it is
manifest that during the time
men live without a common power to keep
them all in awe
they are in that condition which is
called war and such
a war as is of every man against every
man for
war consisteth not in battle only or the
act of fighting but an attractive time
wherein the will to contend by battle is
sufficiently
known right so
now is there a direct mapping between
what hobbes is talking about
and the dark forest hypothesis or the
dark forest
condition not exactly
and lujin has already made this
abundantly clear by saying listen
with human beings at least we can rely
on some things
helping us to to work with each other
you know the chain of suspicion can end
at a certain point
and it does also for hobbs right hobbs
sketches out how that could be the the
case
in the rest of leviathan it takes
certain conditions to make it happen but
it's it's feasible
truly alien species where we don't
understand the mentality but there is a
strategic thinking going on
you could call it a hyper hobbesian
situation
right the whole idea of the chain of
suspicion
and not being able to know whether
somebody's benevolent
in part because benevolence is defined
merely as not malevolent
not being able to know that and then
therefore having to
attack knowing also what hobbs is called
diffidence that
if it's going through my mind it's also
going through their minds as well at
least we can rely on on that
there isn't going to be any sort of they
started out
uh you know suspicious and then they
arrive at
a lack of suspicion a trust there's no
possibility of that
in this universe and why not well in
part because there is no
hobbesian sovereign who could ever be
gotten here it would just be another
galactic civilization and they would
wipe you out
as they do with earth's solar system
in the third book death's end
right we see a very interesting
depiction of a very minor
functionary who's allowed to send the
the
weapon that destroys earth's solar
system and destroys most of mankind
now this is only partly hobbesian right
and it's partly beyond it as well
this whole idea of of the dark forest
means that every species would be
essentially
stuck in its own
state or they would and get they would
engage in the sort of conversation that
happens between trisolaris
and earth where they essentially think
of us as bugs who need to be pushed out
so that they can colonize
because we would do that to them just as
well
and it's interesting because they're
able to get some earth collaborators and
the beginning of the story
you know uh this is a little bit of a
side note
lou talks about um what would it be like
to
to
want to betray humanity to view humanity
as
as not worth saving in this sort of case
and
the cultural revolution provides a
matrix where people can be so
dismayed and dishonored and
you know essentially misanthropized
that that could be the case and they
could participate in the earth
trisolaris
organization which betrays humanity
there's another thing that comes up that
we we need to talk about
with this particular theme as well
so the the battle in the darkness what
is that referring to
when trisolaris destroys the earth fleet
seven ships escape two of them
are ships that are in the earth fleet
that are there to meet the probes you
know doing a show of strength and they
manage to get
outside of you know they get they
they get outside the battle area they
get outside of the solar system
and they're you know moving along
as fast as they can the other is
one of the flagships of one of the
fleets
gets taken by a cryogenically preserved
and then brought to the present
the narrative present officer who
gets control over the ship through you
know essentially
normal methods we could say and then
takes it
out into space for other ships pursuing
it
and at the time that the attack on the
fleet destroying all the rest of the
earth fleet
happens these ships are
these five ships over here are outside
of the solar system
moving out into the the galaxy
now the fleet is destroyed and
communications happen and suddenly the
the two ships that escaped
and the um five ships that are you know
one of which has has uh fled and four
are in pursuit
become aware of the fact that they may
be all of humanity that survives
the tricelarian fleet when it arrives if
it's armed with the same sort of
of things as these these two probes that
destroyed everything
boy prospects for humanity are not good
so suddenly humanity which
before had had you know there had been
the possibility of what was called
escapism the idea that we should like go
out into the stars and and get away from
the trisolarians or even get away from
earth and it was it was condemned it was
actually forbidden legally
because it was thought it would lead to
you know to kind of
screw everybody else the elites get to
leave you know it would violate our
humanity
now we've got humanity out in space
and a hobbesian situation a dark forest
situation emerges out of it each of the
ships
begins to realize we don't
really as a fleet have enough resources
for the new humanity that we are to
continue
the long journey that we're going to be
on
so what should we do
you know the other ship could be looked
at not just as a set of comrades
but as prey as something to be exploited
as something to be despoiled this is the
first hobbs in reason for conflict right
people invade for gain and so
if i'm in ship a i will invade
ship b because i can take their fuel i
can take their spare parts
i can take the protein of the human
beings
the bodies that are there we're going to
need protein
to live on right so we'll
kill them and strip all of their
resources we'll set off a bomb that you
know
kills everybody on board but leaves the
ship as something that we can
we can use now if that's going out in my
head
what's going on in the head of the
person who is in the other ship who's in
charge
the same identical process because we're
both rational
we both see the the problem that we're
in we're both smart
we're both you know used to making
difficult decisions because we're all
military ships
that means that i'd better get uh if
they're already thinking about that i
better attack before they do
there shouldn't be any communication
there shouldn't be any sort of
engagement
it's it's a quick draw situation and
we'd better
knock it out immediately and that is
indeed what happens with the the dark
uh forest the battle in the darkness
with both of the ships which shows that
humanity itself
can break down in that way and then
they're considered traitors for a while
they're also considered
heroes for a while human beings views on
them
very considerably so this is a good
place to end
this particular discussion
we've really only explored two main
philosophical themes there's many other
philosophical themes
that we can talk about with respect to
uh lou see shin's wonderful
trilogy here and some of his other ideas
has communicated in
interviews and other works
[Music]
you